hello and welcome to gender next week
there were lots of committee meetings
back in Brussels let's take a look at
the highlights Commissioner Cecilia
Muslims trade version is so far gotten a
tepid response if I am ep's can she gone
a bigger interest when she makes an
appearance at the Parliament on
Wednesday there are huge concerns over
Europe's trade deal with the u.s. the
Commission has promised more
transparency negotiations and has tried
to allay fears over GMOs and investment
protection clauses can miss Malstrom do
enough to smooth things over follow the
debate on Wednesday they are sanctions
that across the EU some five billion
euros a spat between Russia and the EU
over the Ukraine crisis got a bit uglier
and a bit closer to home when Russia
bannson EU food exports producers of
basic staples like meat fruit and veg
other worse affected the EU says it will
do all it can to help last week the
Commission announced a 28 million a
package for Baltic milk producers what's
next find out when agriculture
commissioner Phil Hogan stops by on
Wednesday talking to Europe LTV economic
and financial affairs commissioner
Pierre Moscovici reaffirmed the younger
Commission's growth planet to continue
on a path of stability and consolidation
you can watch that interview on the
channel and catch him at the Parliament
on Tuesday where he's also expect to
talk about fiscal governance in Italy
and in France the countdown for the lux
prize begins as screenings for three
shortlisted movies its start from monday
girl hoods been creating a big buzz but
is it worth the height from the first
profs embo be able to catch either
girlhood and class enemy at the
Parliament don't forget to bring the
popcorn and a quick reminder that the EU
african caribbean and pacific countries
conference gets underway in strasbourg
from monday and europe all TV will be
covering all the events and that's what
we have this agenda take care and enjoy
the week
you